il était une fois une princesse qu'une
malédiction avait plongé dans un sommeil
éternel seul un baiser témoignant d'un
amour sincère pouvait la
réveiller mais aucun prince ne vint
jamais
elle hte mes rêves plongé dans le
sommeil attend mon baiser le jour où je
la trouverai
[Applaudissements]
enfin allô CVE kaer est décédé c'est à
moi qu'il a légué sa maison je n'ai pas
davantage d'information nous sommes
seulement l'exécuteur testamentaire
comment est-il
mort vous connaissiez mon oncle non
c'était un solitaire Thomas quand tu
arriveras à kaer Gardens sache qu'il y a
des règles à respecter de par ta ligé tu
as accès à à l'ensemble de la
propriété ça m'est arrivé deux nuits de
suite c'est la première fois que c'est
aussi
rapproché non je ne rêve pas c'est trop
réel je suis toujours
endormi et j'attends ton
baiser pourquoi vous m'aider maintenant
vous êtes piégé dans cette maison et moi
je veux retrouver mon frère ce sont des
esprits on les appelle de plusieurs
façons démons fantômes ou jein mais on
en trouve quasiment
partout je dois lever la malédiction
c'est quoi du S je
crois si on arrive à trouver orore rose
et à la réveiller on lèvera la
malédiction
[Musique]